hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to inscription
everything's Brighton here and there's
something moving over here which I think
is just this dude here you're the camera
oh
hi
oh interesting
interesting oh there's a door back there
and a gravestone
that's fascinating
that's interesting it makes me wonder
what was what else was hiding in the
darkness beforehand
huh
I think oh it represents the other three
things right the door is leshy the the
pedestal with the the shape is the magic
dude and then the gravestone is
obviously the death bug interesting very
interesting
hmm
okay though so what's all this about
what's that going on there
yeah why are you not printing why is it
not printing po3
what is it doing whoa
hold the phone
I saw you there what's uh what was uh
all that about what uh would um that the
Slime Guy then Payne slime man
in pain Slyman is that what that was
possibly okay whatever all right let's
get back to the game
time to go all right so if we got memory
card is full
oh
oh
more
than
interesting hmm
ah fun
well hello there card Gamers
um looks like my garage sale hunting
days have finally paid off
yeah yeah
baby why don't you guys do this
you know what that is you know what that
is vintage packs of inscription four of
them
I don't know if the woman knew what
these are worth I mean I felt a little
bad buying them off of her
but I mean she's probably doing okay
living in this part of town
it's a nice part of that you know and uh
she would have thrown them away if I
hadn't come by right right right yeah
right pack opening video and come in
all right cool cool man yeah have fun
with it
was a long one
bottom of what
bottom of this whole game thing and how
the FBI is banging down your door
hello
hi hello is this Mrs Hobbs
hi my name is Luke
well it's very nice to speak with you as
well Mrs
hop
um listen I was at your garage sale the
other day and I
no no
everything's fine thank you um I was
just wondering if you remember those
playing cards that you sold me those
yes
yes those ones inscription yes
they were your daughters
would it be possible for me to speak
with her
he passed does he
oh
no I'm so sorry yeah way to go man
oh it was a while ago
that's still
terrible
oh
it's nothing really I'm
sorry to have bothered you man
her name was Casey
sorry what
she worked for inscription I mean she
worked for gamefuna
ma'am would it be possible
I see okay yeah um do you think it'd be
all right if I called you back later I'm
just trying to get to the bottom of
something
okay
okay thank you so much okay
all right have a good dinner
bye stop bothering this poor lady whoa
got corrupted
oh my God
no one was killed at the facility The
Tragically Young video game developer
Casey Hobbs died from fire related
complications
[ __ ]
she was working late at the facility
performing quality assurance on behalf
of her employer whoa
what happening
oh key
mirror roaring Pig 3K Pig
uh okay that was a weird one
what's with this mask
what is that right there that's an
eyeball
that was definitely an eyeball okay
all right
someone is here
my boat's in the other room so if I die
before I can call 9-1-1 and use this
type of evidence
well no one's going to be able to get it
if you go confront
whatever's there and it sees you have a
camera oh
oh no I don't like it
well it looks like whoa what was that
excuse him one
what do we have this
my call log 2 st22
looks like a vertical line P three r h a
p s question question straight line
blood dollar L 3 TT 3r 8ox or box I
think that's eight ox
my colleague to Street tutu perhaps
I don't know if that's a coat or
something all right cool great
oh
great everything seems to be in perfect
order here all done you got all that
good keep that in your brain
it's funky here all right well got that
which means that probably the bones I
see the outline of it the bone zones
right here all right well I have so much
money I need to go spend it so I'm gonna
do that and this is a rabbit pelt I know
what that is now I don't know what that
is though
um
yeah what does it do I'm curious it's
worth a lot of money so it's got to be
good right whoa gives Nano Armor to your
bots on the board decent oh
oh cool
I would go for more cards but I'm kind
of worried about slamming my deck full
of cards hmm there's got to be something
good there there's got to be something
worth it right there's got to be
something worth it
whoa gift bot yay I like gift bot gift
bot sounds great gives me a card one
dies I love that thank you gift bot
you're the gift that keeps on giving
uh yeah why not I got the money you
might as well spend the money
another gift bot I could do that or a
sniper bot is very useful Sentry drone
kind of useful I don't have one I don't
have many one value things yeah I'll do
that I'll do that that could be useful
okay all right it was Mosey let's go
down to Bone Zone maybe I can get some
bone bone cards I did like those
phones on
no not bone Zone opposite of bone Zone
down Zone
ugh the dang scrap yard is pretty
unpleasant its inhabitants grasping
claws seek fresh Bots watch your ankles
okay
oh
uh-huh secret oh
the skeletcher what does that do when a
card bearing the sigil perishes its
owner chooses a creature to gain the
brittle sigil oh
that's good for I guess making something
on the other side brittle
when a card bearing the sigil perishes
its owner chooses a creature to gain the
Nano Armor sigil I mean kind of fun but
the amoebot's been very versatile and
also you don't attack why don't you
attack the brittle thing I I guess I
could see that being useful that means
that no matter what it's always gonna
kill something
but a mibodies is very versatile
I already have a newbie bot let's do
skeletal latcher I could see that being
very very nice when I find something
that I don't want to live any longer
all right amiibot thank you gift bot
all right what's incoming bomb latcher I
don't like the sound of that looks like
a meebot you're gonna go up against a
bomb latch or maybe
um
uh probably best to do this one
oh
try me oh that gets the bomb well that's
fine I don't plan to kill it uh let's
see what kind of cards we can get
um
look at you right there could kill that
and then replace it with the sentry gun
and that would actually kill that thing
on the way in
shabam get gone get out of here get out
of here I should have put it over there
that's that would that'd be useful
yeah I know I know buddy I know buddy
that's okay I didn't plan on him dying
anyway
oh double Gunner okay that's my that's
my dudes
thank you for the double Gunner though
that's very helpful thank you
am I gonna kill it this time yeah I am
actually might as well just do as much
damage as I can
Go baby go
there we go a little Overkill not much
one which is not much
by any definition hey a bounty
power what does this do oh there's a
cool one I'll overclock one of your
cards give it an attack buff but if it
dies it's gone forever oh
oh
um if it dies it's gone forever that
doesn't seem good why would you do that
what kind of buff we talking about here
let's just hang on let's let's talk
about this I haven't even seen swap bot
in Ages full Town what kind of buff we
talking about here what is that
but if a card bearing is still prints
permanently removed from your deck
just does one more attack that's it
there's one more
that's all I guess snipe bot might be
good to have that if I always position
snipe Bots somewhere that he's not gonna
get
God I guess all right he's an overclock
sniper
bam all right good
done don't let it die all right I'll try
not to but I'm not very good about that
so uh
no promises pal friend
no way to go all right let's go oh
all right what do we have uh Shield
latcher is gonna give Shield to that
thing for sure
sentry gun would be good to kill that
Bang
energy the Bloodhound I actually don't
like it it's just been a pain in my ass
okay for energy I'll just do this
try me [ __ ] oh hey it's you again did
you remember the name darling Russ
Thomas Stein and I'm far from dead
okay cool that's a great story man
that's a great story that's a great
story good push up putting that shield
on that tree Really Gonna
probably gonna spice up the place
how much internet energy I got five
all right
man I swear I have more mid mid cost
items but it really doesn't seem that
way
I'm just gonna draw this gift bot ooh
now that's fun
[Music]
I wish I had more cards
oh
oh Shield butt that's
kind of helpful
lonely was bot you're back baby good to
see you good to see you okay
no no no no Shield But You're Gonna Go
There Lonely whiz by you're gonna go
there
Shield The Shield
bam
[Music]
ah snipe bot you're back no one's been
going near my Sentry drone so I could
replace it with this or I could double
Gunner and that would probably be a
better strategy yeah definitely
goodbye
bam hello
my shieldbot no
okay that there sniper bot right there
is this not gonna get attacked and Bubba
of course you would
you're gonna shoot that thing
foreign
s not particularly helpful but I think
I'm gonna win this that thing's gonna
die unless it's still got a shield no
Shield's gone it's gonna die I'm gonna
go
Bam Bam Bam Bam you're dead I got you
ouch it's all right darling remember the
name rust hobestein I'll be back will
you now what about this boom
nice
nice not as much Overkill as I'm capable
of but some
better than dying that's for sure
I don't like these Shield latchers I
love the double Gunner double Gunner is
great but I I guess I don't have a lot
of like mid-cost things but I love the
double Gunner I just love him he's just
great I think he's neat
all right let me bot thank you
what do we have that's a lot of things
oh
fun okay
well I'm gonna take some damage
oh
okay I'm finally up to full energy and I
have no oh swap bot oh swap bot
I love you swap bot bam hit back oh yeah
okay that's good I love that swap bot
haven't seen you in an age
thank you very much thank you thank you
thank you very much appreciate it nice
try and all but whatever not very good
you wish to pass this ice well I suppose
I could clear it a little bit of heat
should do the trick huh
and what's over here
oh
my whoa money
I feel like I just grave robbed but you
know it's fine it's probably fine it's
probably okay
all right what was over here
it's like a shortcut path around in case
I die again I see which I'm not gonna
die so it doesn't matter ready to trade
sure
um I do like the extra skeleton because
it reminds me of the bone things from
before even if it dies it's a quick two
damage
it's hard to remove uh uh oh honestly
get rid of this bloodhound
honestly like I I don't know what it is
but I just don't like them
get out of here what do I do with these
pelts by the way I have pelts still and
I don't know what they're for
Robux
Robo bucks
pick one I will
oh
can I give him more
could I give him some more here we go oh
he's gonna be so stimulated
give him sniper
oh my God oh my God yes please the
memory unit on that one is basically
full now it's Opie enough anyways not
stimulated enough
not enough my friend not enough
nothing nearly enough
not nearly enough
okay what do you got automaticon and a
bomb latcher I see how you do I see how
you do I see what you're doing
try me [ __ ] out out of you
hmm
if I do this it's just gonna put a bomb
on the bomb and that'll be fine because
I can take the hits as I build up energy
yeah cause it's gonna attack this
I'm just gonna die put a bomb on the
bomb and that's fine it's not a big deal
so I'm gonna take another one of these
I'm gonna put it right there put the XC
skeleton right there so it can do the
damage it needs to do and then that'll
blow up and do basically uh nothing
actually those are gonna move forward oh
[ __ ]
forgot about that hey what's a pill
couldn't catch zip Von boat last time
this time I'll be sure to catch your
scalp
okay wait hold on please let that not
kill me okay we're good
put a bomb on the rails good job
all right we're fine we're fine we're
fine we're all good I'm Gonna Make You
brittle I'm Gonna Make You brittle my
guy okay so if I put that there he's
gonna get killed by that thing
uh
uh yeah let me grab this just because I
can and I'm gonna put that there because
he's gonna shoot that and then I'm gonna
make him brittle and he's gonna go
bye-bye
that's what he gonna do
try me [ __ ] oh be brutal
goodbye I'll be taking that scalp
Another Day You Ain't Seen the Last zip
on board no I think I have actually I
think I have
amiibo cool cool cool you got nothing
you got nothing my dude you got nothing
you got nothing my dude I'm a dude you
got nothing oh you got some you got
things now you weren't supposed to got
things double gun right uh let me hold
off on putting anything there just yet
oh you guys are gonna attack over those
things
probably for the best
yeah
uh
and that's fine because I can double gun
simulation I know right right pal yeah
that's good one bam don't matter bang a
boom
easy
thank you
another lovely game very fun very fun
I had any items are back online bot
spawners are offline
okay good I didn't even use my items
that time through
what a depressing Abode you have to be
here to defeat the resident uberbot but
I don't think you'll want to stay long
let me back up a step before I go
anywhere
has anything changed
whoa what is that
what is that about
why is there a skull there
whoa that's weird there's something
going on here my guys
there's something going on here my dudes
something's going on all right whatever
it's fine for now it's fine let me uh
figure this out
oh but do I want to
the supercharge is nice but not me yeah
no not you also I can't do the other one
because it's
too much man all these are gonna die if
they die I mean it would be nice to swap
by because that would give him a little
more Health but it's not really the
problem here you know what I mean all
right let me let me do a double Gunner
because I have extras of those I can I
can afford that I know he's very fragile
but that's like twice as much upgrade
all right whatever it's fine it's fine
it's fine
it's fine hello
hey
I like the exoskeleton
that's a very good one easy dablish
trading hmm
okay what do you got
energy bot always good I like energy bot
I do like energy bot a new experience
yeah I'm not gonna trade you my dude
skelecher was very valuable
Sonia is meh
I'm very indifferent on Sonia yeah Sonia
you're gone energy bot all the way
oh
gotcha don't know what I'm gathering
those for but I sure am Gathering them
before I do any boss fight let me see
what we got going on here oh what is
that what is that trapdoor it's like a
trap door there
weird
oh hi
halt we require commitment to pass you
must agree to Grant access to the
archivists what are these like these
adeptus mechanicus okay all right do you
agree to Grant access it is important
you must sign this contract oh you
cannot sign this contract you do not
have a writing utensil
okay all right then I'll go get one
thanks Bill thanks buddy
energy boss I love energy but thank you
all right uh Shield by I'll put that on
that Sentry drone
I guess it'll die anyway but if it's got
nothing to put a shield on by the time
it dies maybe that's better
maybe that's good ah whatever screw it
oh we put a shield on me oh that's
extremely great oh thank you thank you
pal
thank you thank you very much oh you are
just the sweetest you're just the
sweetest thing ain't you just a sweetest
thing
thank you energy bot you're a lifesaver
I love you
I love you
what do we got there flying and shield
latcher
[Music]
double Gunner okay that's fine that's
fine that's fine okay more important to
defend against that damage I think than
try to stop oh it can't anyway it's
flying it'll just come right over me are
those over oh those are overclocked
that's why they're all zappy Maybe
nah I don't know
probably
yeah whatever
oh
gift bolt
I need to inflict some pain
but I also need to stop this guy from
inflicting pain I hate to use the
exoskeleton this way but I think I gotta
it's just the best move I think
thanks for the shield baby
thank you for the delightful Shield that
is awfully nice of you
exercise and you say that is going to be
particularly useful for dealing with
this bastard here
how grateful I am to you well well I
suppose I could have done double Gunner
but I think it was more important to
kill that thing
[Music]
and this just so happens to be my
overcharge double Gunner which I like
very much
[Music]
thank you I win
oh yeah
a little a little extra credit
I mean I think my deck is pretty much
good enough I don't need to do too much
oh a quill who had the quill before
interesting okay it said something about
signing the contract but there is this
over here
hmm
hmm well that looks dangerous
uh shooty Tootie that is that is uh
gonna be a lot of damage you gonna do to
me but uh not today
yeah not today
uh
um gift could go down I guess
it's not gonna kill it I don't know if
it does that every turn but at least I
can put it down
oh
I should have both blastwick
let's get down to business all right
okay I guess right two then it's a
little a little abrupt but whatever the
other one's an insecto Droid okay
just the way I like it
who's refer to say all right I need a
shield bot down for this guy
and if that doesn't die in the next one
I'll just kill myself
I should probably use my items I'm gonna
take one damage and that'll probably be
one damage too many I'm gonna risk it
for the Biscuit My Biscuits
oh
Sentry drone that doesn't do me too much
good I can't defend against that but I
can't shoot it out of the air let's go
snip you bot
and Sentry drones just in case he puts
anything here
goodbye
oh sniper bot might be in trouble oh God
no sniper bot no can I win this oh God
sniper bot no oh God no I can't put my
double Gunner down oh no sniper bot no
no sniper bot please not like this oh
God it's very sad Shield
yes I'm gonna use the shield that's what
I'm gonna do put you down there yeah
Shield everyone up I could put a me bot
down but it wouldn't do me a lot of good
because he'd die right there Shield
please thank you
sniper lives to snipe another day
barely
oh I should have just destroyed that
I'll get it next time
try me [ __ ] stupid
that's not as helpful now wish I got
that earlier can't put double Gunner
down because that's there let me just go
ahead and Destroy This dude
uh again please thank you
ah helpful very helpful
for you there that's okay
and you kill that one that one that one
all gone hey my injuries are severe I
shall retire for now
then you're gone and then guess what I
get to do
I get to put down my double Gunner my
super double Gunner right in the spot
where you don't have any coverage oh God
those might kill my dude
it's fine
draw a card you're right you're right
when you write you write
okay I gotta win this
one two three four five six seven eight
that's gonna do two that's gonna do six
that's a win it's not Overkill but it's
it's good enough
bam
almost lost my guys
almost lost them like forever or
whatever
oops
all right what's up this way nothing I
can do yet okay cool got that settled
let's go fight uh or sign this contract
you have brought a fine quill please
sign here you agree that you agree to
give access thank you do not forget your
agreement
what access are we talking about
what part of me are you about to access
also what is this thing I feel like
there's a puzzle that I'm not solving in
this but whatever all right anyway back
to it
oh that's the same point that looks like
I'm about to about to fight an uberbot
or something like that
let's go for it let's see what happens
there it is the Uber bot you sought
these idiotic Librarians worship it as
it sits here covered in filth and grime
ready to clean it up oh yeah
oh look it's boss time unpacking
archivist.zip applying personality rate
matrices cleaning up some temp files
okay here we go
hi ah greetings
if you had not cleaned it from the title
of my zip file I am the archivist I
eagerly await the opportunity to explore
your hard drive files and directories
are my special to you see
okay
what does that mean I don't know how
this fight is gonna go okay pretty cool
librarian Dead Bite when a card bearing
the digital parishes select a file Place
damage on the scales according to the
file's size
huh okay I don't understand it but okay
I'll do what I can
ow
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh I should have inquired sooner you
will need a Grammy access to your hard
drive would you please acquiesce I
assure you no harm will come to it
Francis Christian exe permission to
access your hard drive
yeah okay all right here comes your
actual files oh boy I hope no one is
watching
uh now do recommend an exemplary file to
me and do take into account its size its
magnitude it's bulk
I think I know of a file a video preview
one of these is very large
157 gigabytes I was going to delete this
anyway it's a preview file I have a file
that's 157 gigabytes do I have any 175
gigabytes these are video file
286 gigabytes these are actually my
actual video render files uh from when I
do editing and when you're working with
like high resolution footage sometimes
the video previews can be incredibly big
but also help speed up editing here's a
little editing tip everybody try to
pre-render whenever you can I think 286
is the biggest one all right let's see
what happens
my word this file it is I must say it is
colossal
Bravo thank you
I know
did I win what what did I win that's the
biggest file I got 286 gigabytes ain't
doing it for you
what do you mean I didn't do any for you
all right whatever if this is how this
game's gonna go I got more files where
that's coming from you know what I mean
I don't think it's deleting them but I
think it's just accessing them I think
that's none of my porn collection
all right let's put uh Another Empty
vessel because these seem to be good for
just taking care of these dudes
and if I put in a me bot there it's just
going to make it not do any damage so
that's helpful all right cool
well you know
the file size is really why I'm here
everybody again choose a file the file
size will be Paramount I'm going to the
same exact place
175 gigabytes there you go magnificent
it is gargantuan I know I am aware my
friend I know please select a file
however this one is very special choose
a file that is dearest to your heart and
one that shows age interesting I don't
have too many old files because this
computer is relatively new where would
my oldest file be
[Music]
well obviously when the computer was
installed I go to Windows it don't
delete these do not delete these These
are technically the oldest on my
computer because they're when I got them
oh 2004.
that's like a Windows source file don't
delete this please tell me you're not
about to delete this please do not
delete these it is about as old as it
can get
now let us place that file in a card you
didn't choose a file that was it's a
Windows File please don't delete it for
if this card dies I will delete this
file from your disk please that's a
Windows File please do not tempt me I am
completely serious shall we see what
that looks like
oh God no this file is most ancient
indeed it has seen things yeah
a stat line of 4-4 is only appropriate
for an August file such as this Dear God
please don't delete that it's a Windows
File I don't know what it does but I'm
pretty sure it's important so please
this
if I used to create is really deleted
from your hard drive oh my God
oh my God my entire
dark I'm getting around here bro I'm not
joking
I'm putting it down because it's very
powerful it's very powerful so I'm gonna
put it down but if you delete it
okay we have an understanding we have an
understanding
[Music]
oh God no don't make it brittle don't
don't I see you there making it brittle
you do not please dear God can I
I'm gonna win it it's gonna it's one
the day is one
please tell me it's one
okay energy bot okay I'm just gonna make
sure that the day is one because I don't
like putting any of this to chance I'm
gonna let's see I'm gonna get rid of you
you're not my supercharged double Gunner
but you'll have to do I'm gonna use this
I'm gonna plop this double Gunner down
there I'm gonna put a shield
s on these bad boys over here
and then we're gonna see what happens
I win right I win
okay thank you my God
you
didn't
[Music]
I thought I had you oh well
you made a few correct deck building
decisions I guess and you're lucky
I haven't really been able to pick my
deck you know it's kind of just what
happens to me
what is the goose I don't ah gooching
back to the gravestone of course
thank you thank you for that thank you
appreciate thank you for that thank you
degrees and what is this again I forget
what this is oh you're gonna upgrade my
dudes
hell yeah hell yeah
ooh
oh
oh my God yes are you kidding me are you
joking me yes give me the battery yes
give me the battery are you joking me
all right now what's different
it's got to be something different here
there's a wait there's a
there's a little crossbone on that now I
don't think that was there before
because I was there before
okay all right I think that's whoa wait
what the frick
oh how annoying
the other scribes junk sometimes
glitches in here try to ignore it I
won't
what was the oh what was it
I don't remember what the actual time
was oh what was it I don't remember what
it was but I think it was pretty early
on oh
[Music]
thank you everybody so much for watching
that's all the time I have for this
episode I now have an aurora robot
which is going to be my big ass
kickerbot good to have you back bud good
to have you back so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought down in the comments below
and look forward to more inscription
very soon and as all I will see you in
the next video bye-bye
[Music]